foreign
I feel often that I do have a sugar
addiction but I don't even know if
that's real man so the approach that we
tend to have towards diet in general is
is terrible so I think the fail rate
last time I checked was north of 85 and
this is like within the first couple
years and I bet you it's closer to 95 if
you stretch it out
[Music]
hey what's going on this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
show about your marriage show about your
kids show about dating whatever's going
on in your life you go about school
about
um your mental health whatever is going
on in your life I'm I'm John deloney
here and I am
dedicated to sitting with you
figuring out what comes next Walking
alongside Jeff that works out better for
you some people like sitting some people
like walking whatever it works out
um but I'm here for you if you want to
be on this show shoot me an email at
John deloney.com ask a-s-k and um let me
know what's going on your life and it
will go to Jenna and she will make the
call or may go to Kelly it's been kind
of mood Kelly said maybe maybe Jenna and
then we'll decide she'll make some
choices build a great show and have you
on be amazing
um before I head to the first call today
we're recording this show
um it's been a tragic shooting at a
small Elementary School here in town and
so I've been on the phone all morning
and it's an absolute just it's just
it's
um heartbreaking
all over again and again and again and
again and and
um
I hope that the words never get trite
that we're praying for those families
that are forever devastated they will
never not be devastated
um for the First Responders that showed
up and the things that they saw and the
things they experienced and the lives
they tried to save the little bitty
little bitty lives and the grown-up
lives and everybody just the whole thing
the whole thing my heart's broken and
um hope you'll join me praying for those
families and at some point we gotta
address the madness we just gotta dress
the madness across the board
all right let's go out to uh Heather in
Reno Heather what's going on
um so my question is am I wrong for
wanting to end my engagement because my
fiance doesn't want to get a job and
also wants me to move in
um to his great uncle's house with him
after getting married
no end it this is the easiest call of my
entire show ever
yes and why are you even asking the
question
I don't know I just thought maybe there
was something else I could be doing
so that we could move forward he doesn't
want to move forward with you
okay and right
I guess so yeah have you told him I'm
not gonna marry you unless you have a
job or I'm not going to marry you if
your plan for housing is that we move in
with my uncle
yeah I did give him in February I gave
him the boundary that if by the end of
March
he didn't have a job or start therapy
that I didn't really think I could see
myself continuing the relationship so I
want I want to flip around it's more of
an ultimatum than a boundary but I want
to flip your ultimatum around
good for you you drew a line in the sand
and said this is where me and my values
stop
and he chose to not marry you
I don't want you wearing around I don't
want you being a martyr here like I had
to end this thing because I I
you were strong and brave and very clear
here is my standards for somebody that
I'm gonna hitch my wagon to
and someone who's going to Hitch their
wagon to me and that we're going to do
life together forever
come hell or high water here's my line
and he said I don't want that I'm out
yeah
um just to go back
um
to give more detail into this
um his uncle did start having some
health problems in the middle of
February okay
um and so
he felt responsibility to take care of
him
and so I tried being supportive and
understanding like I did really want to
support him and his family
through this hard time but
um
I just didn't really feel like a
priority
um and so I'm kind of like
I feel selfish because I'm like why I
almost feel like I'm making him choose
between me and
his family
hmm
why won't he get a job
because he says that he needs to take
care of his uncle
how does he have money for food
um his uncle helps provide financially
so what about another reason why he
wanted us to live with his uncle because
we wouldn't have to be
um we wouldn't have the financial burden
of rent
why do you think so little about what
you want and so little about what you
need
I don't know I want to say because I
love him and
they do want I do see a future with him
but he doesn't see one with you
because here's what I think I think that
before this happened in February
I think he didn't work either
yeah and I think before this happened in
February he was kind of a freeloader
anyway
and before this happened in February you
were already thinking I I can't just
I love you we've had some great fun
times together
but I can't I can't commit myself for
the rest of my life
to somebody who has so little drive so
little desire to hear what I need and to
help meet my needs
um
I I think you know that going in I don't
think you're selfish
yeah
this would be totally different if he
was going to law school or he's in year
three of a computer science degree or
he's already working as a as a as a
like a plumbing apprentice and he was
making some money and he had plans for
getting a good job and whatever and then
all of a sudden a bomb dropped in his
family and he had to stop what he was
doing to go care for somebody that's
Noble that's incredible and that happens
a lot and I have a feeling that if that
were the case you'd be all in
yeah
am I is that is that right
yeah yeah definitely I would be like yes
I will support you like I'm here for you
so has he always since you've known him
been a fun
whatever guy blah blah blah it's so cute
all that stuff but he's also been kind
of lazy
I don't know if I would say lazy but I
do see a lack of Drive in him and that
was hard to
um
hard to swallow because I like I really
like
have I have goals and I want to grow and
change and
um sometimes it just felt like he was
really okay with being
in the same exact spot
in his life how old are you
I'm sorry that your heart's broken
yeah
I'm sorry
because I don't really know like what
else I can do other than I'm gonna tell
you nothing zero things
okay
there's there's nothing there's not a
conversation you haven't magically said
there's not a thing you haven't like oh
maybe if I just wear this nothing
yeah you've heard me say this a million
times behavior is a language
and so yeah he may not be saying it but
what he's saying with through the way
he's his actions are is
I'm gonna take the easiest Road out for
me at any given moment
and right as you told him here's your
ultimatum uncle got sick and he's like
oh that'll solve all of our problems
yeah
and you can see the short-term thinking
this will just get us this will cover
our rent and this will cover our food
yeah there's nothing about what is
career going to look like what is 10
years from now what is our family
situation going to look like where would
kids live I mean none of that it's very
short-term very egocentric very childish
thinking
okay right
yeah
and I'm heartbroken for you because I
know you I know you love this kid
yeah
and you wish he was the guy that would
be your guy and I'm hearing you say he's
not
yeah and I guess the One Shining Light
in the dark here is that you're not
married and you don't have two kids and
you're just now coming to this
realization
yeah I just
it got to the point where
I felt like I was going into the
marriage knowing it was going to end in
divorce
and I just didn't
I I can't tell you how proud of you I am
most people don't have the courage to
as I say all the time turn the lights on
turn the music off and say what are we
doing
stop the party we got somebody stop the
train because I'm getting off I just
gotta stop for a second
and that's not to say that
um
two years from now that he doesn't call
you and be like hey man I'm I was
immature little brat and here I am now
I'm doing this and this and this and
yeah he can take you for we gonna take
you for coffee that kind of thing right
that's how the movie would end right
um
that's that's nothing that's not gonna
happen what I'm saying here is
I stand behind you 100 Heather
well you know deep in your bones which
you know through experience which you
know that you want when you look out and
say this is the kind of relationship I
want to have it's the kind of marriage I
want to have this is the kind of life I
want to have
you know you've got a very clear Lane a
clear picture of what that looks like
what you're telling me is he's not it
[Music]
huh
you're gonna spend a season and
heartbreak and a season of grief and a
season of sadness and that's okay that's
right
but don't compromise your values and
don't compromise who you are and don't
compromise who you want to become and
who you're becoming
just because it's uncomfortable and hard
right now
I'm proud of you sticking to your guns
I can never help holler at me and thank
you so much for the call we'll be right
back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we're back it's time for
everybody's favorite segment facts are
your friends let's do it
foreign
all right so um
I I one of the most common questions I
get
um I get we get lots of questions about
sex and intimacy you get lots of
questions about mental health
um and over the last year or two one of
the most common questions I get is about
weight loss and all of the drama that
that surrounds weight loss whether it's
um Instagram nonsense or just outdated
stuff or your mom drank Tab and watched
like VHS tapes when you were a kid and
you've just picked up some of those
habits telling this whatever is going on
uh so here's the thing
I don't have expertise here
um and so I invited my friend Sal to
Stefano from mind pump he's he's the are
you the leader of the gang cell no no
we're all we're all equal Partners hey
you know who says that the Don the true
leader says that that that way in case
it all goes down everybody gets shot not
just not just the leader
um I invited my friend uh Sal on just to
ask a question that is coming up later
on in the show and I just wanted his
expertise um Sal is has been a personal
trainer has been a trainer of trainers
and is now one of um the very few voices
I trust out in the world talking about
Fitness and Nutrition
um Sal thank you so much it's a last
minute call and you're helping me out
today and you're especially helping out
our listeners thank you so much for
joining me man John thanks for having me
on it you guys you know we absolutely
love what you do uh out there and uh
when we met you just uh you're about as
genuine as they come so I of course I
jumped to the opportunity to be able to
help you out or hop on here I appreciate
it all right so here's the question that
I I've got coming in on my show so when
you and I get off the phone this
person's gonna gonna call in and this is
their question that they they typed up
and sent to us
um it's from Jay in uh Michigan says I'm
addicted to sugar and I'm making poor
choices with food I'm afraid if I don't
get it under control I'm gonna die early
or end up on that show my 600 pound life
how can I get get a gauge on this and
change my life
so
the first question I want to ask you Sal
is what's the what's the truth or drama
around sugar addiction I talk about it
all the time like I like I'm some kind
of heroin addict and I I feel often that
I do have a sugar addiction but I don't
even know if that's real man so you have
any wisdom there
yeah um I mean technically you can
develop an addictive
relationship with almost anything now I
know the way that they try to explain
or describe addictive substances is
through the physiological responses
things like dopamine and serotonin and
but I mean you can develop a
dysfunctional relationship that would
mirror what we would consider classic
addiction with almost anything
and food is definitely up there and I
think foods that are hyper palatable or
bring us Comfort or help numb us or
maybe we have some other I don't know
connection to a particular type of food
are probably the ones that are most most
likely
um for us to contr to develop these
behaviors with but you know what are the
Hallmarks of addiction is that you it is
dramatically decreasing the quality of
your life and you continue to do it um
anyway now in that category I mean I
think a lot of people a good chunk of us
have some type of uh dysfunctional
relationship with food this is why
obesity is such such a common thing
um and you know soon here I think it'll
be a majority of Americans yeah so it's
it's a it's a real thing it's really
challenging
um but the approach that we tend to have
towards diet in general is is terrible
it fails it's I think the fail rate last
time I checked was north of 85 percent
and this is like within the first couple
years and I bet you it's closer to 95 if
you stretch it out uh far enough so it's
the approach the approach is all wrong
we focus on the physiological we focus
on the the weight loss and I know those
are all things that people are looking
for but it goes much deeper than that
um
so the the joke that's not really a joke
is I've always said getting off of sugar
stopping uh um sugar Cravings or just
not grabbing candy all the time is is
challenging because nobody I'll say
nobody most work environments don't have
you know joints and cocaine laid out
next to the coffee in the morning like
they do donuts and gummy bears and so
it's pervasive it's everywhere right
um
there's that but there's also like you
mentioned this approach and so that's my
second question here is somebody calls
and says
I can't stop
my my
tough love approach is to to look
somebody in the eye and and put my hands
on the shoulders and say yes you can
but I think that that's just a
derivative of the meta narrative which
is if you're overweight it's because
you're lazy and you're a bum and you
just don't want it bad enough there's
got to be another way to to communicate
love and connectivity and here's what
health looks like what's the path man
yeah it's um it's 100 true it's um it'd
be like looking at you know talking to
somebody who struggles with their
finances and just saying well just make
more money and save more money it's like
well yeah duh
um I guess the steps
can can seem simple but how we get to
those steps
um and how we're able to maintain those
steps
is very complicated so I'll start with
this
um we typically modern societies we
don't eat because we're hungry most
people have never really even felt what
true hunger feels like most people never
go a day without food
so the relationships that we build
around food are based off of lots of
other things
um stress anxiety connecting with people
celebrating boredom uh just hedonistic
pleasure so these are the types of
relationships that we build around food
so just to Simply say to yourself don't
eat that eat this
that might work for very robotic type
fanatical individuals who end up working
in the fitness industry
that doesn't work that doesn't work for
most people so you have to and this is
going to sound a bit esoteric and out
there but I can give people steps to
kind of get to this place but
you have to understand why you're eating
the way you're eating
what does that food make you feel how
can we get that feeling otherwise and
also what is motivating you and if if
what's motivating you is
uh I'm gross I'm fat
um you know I don't look good
um you know anything negative along
those lines it's not going to stick it's
just not going to stick because if
you're doing this because you're gross
fat unattractive inadequate then not
eating food is going to feel restrictive
or not eating the foods that you enjoy
or whatever that relationship is with
that food is going to feel restrictive
and then along those lines exercise is
going to feel like a punishment right
you have to go about it by understanding
that the reason why you're going to
choose to eat the way that you're now
going to eat
is because you're caring for yourself
okay now I say you're doing this because
you love yourself but the reason why I
said care is because when I say love
people think
it's a it's the feeling of love like
this warm fuzzy feeling
um but no I mean the action right like I
have kids John and uh look sometimes I
don't get that warm fuzzy feeling for
them teenage kids
dude sometimes I don't feel that feeling
sometimes I'm like man you're pushing it
buddy but I choose to love them yeah
through action so if you say to yourself
I'm going to care for myself like
somebody I care about what does that
look like and start there
then eating right it doesn't feel
restrictive it's self-care and and
that's a much more balanced long-term
approach and it doesn't result or it
typically doesn't result in the
Rebellion that we tend to see when
people do it from a place of self-hate
because when people do it from a place
of self-hate what happens when they go
off a diet right they don't just eat one
cookie or one slice of pizza they eat
the whole box so they eat a whole pizza
until they until they're uncomfortable
it's they Rebel they're rebelling from
the self-hate right so so it's got to
come from a place of self-care that's
number one if you don't do that nothing
else I'm going to say is going to make
sense no diet is going to work for you
no structured anything's gonna work for
you you got to go from a point of
self-care now if you start there then we
can talk about the steps and what that
looks like and how we can develop the
skills that go along with that what
those skills look like because they are
skills you do have to develop them you
do have to learn how to live in this
Society where there's all kinds of
amazing incredible foods that we're
surrounded by that are super easy to get
to
um and inexpensive but you got to start
from a place of self-care that's
incredible man
um
gosh and
that's a tough
um
I'm just thinking here mechanistically
that's that's a tough message
today
um
because
everybody's at war with themselves I
know very few people who are truly happy
with what they see in the mirror and
even more so I know a few people who are
truly happy with their a lot in life you
and I were just joking before we got on
here like that you and I like
we like we like our lives right I I
didn't understand and I liked my life
when I was in other jobs before I took
this I didn't realize how rare that was
and so but
the actual going to the gym the actual
being mindful of what you're putting in
your body those actions are the same so
what you're saying is we just got to
burn a different kind of fuel I always
tell folks man if you're if you're if
you are trying to change your mental
health trying to stop drinking
because you're gonna show them you got
about six months on that one right
that's just jet fuel and it burns out
real fast and so what you're saying is
no we may end up doing a lot of the same
stuff
but you gotta have a different feel that
you're burning it's got to be because
you're worth it yes and you gotta look I
I totally understand I have all the
compassion and empathy in the world for
this challenge because
first off uh the reason why this is so
hard John is because
who knows you better than you right I
know all my terrible thoughts I know all
the bad things I I do or want to do I
know all my imperfections like how could
I possibly
love myself like I love my kids right
like I know how all these bad tendencies
that I have you know you very well but
that's again it's not the feeling
it's the it's the can I let me take care
of myself and it's also not necessarily
looking the mirror and being happy with
what you see
you don't have to lie to yourself this
isn't like I you know if I can look in
the mirror and I can say to myself
man
I really haven't taken care of myself
like uh somebody that deserves to be
cared for and I can tell I can tell I
haven't taken care of myself but I
deserve I deserve to be cared for so I'm
gonna try doing that now that's really
all it is I like that I deserve to be
careful and it's that that care starts
with me no one's like I can't Outsource
that that's I've got to decide I'm
worthy of care so where do you tell
somebody who's
um like when I'm just looking across the
the
the buffet of choices here does somebody
start with a counselor does somebody
start with a medical doctor to somebody
start with a personal trainer like where
do you start
if you were to hire if you were in this
situation and you were to hire
um a professional
in my experience the best success I ever
had was when because I was a trainer
okay so I knew exercise and I knew
nutrition from uh calorie macro nutrient
micronutrient you know performance and
then later on I got better at
understanding things like food
intolerances and that kind of stuff so
if I had a client who hired me
and also worked with a therapist
and the therapist and I could work
together the success rate was
astronomical astronomical I love it and
because I'm not a therapist so I can
talk about exercise I could talk about
diet but the therapist is is an expert
and the other things that we need to
work on and then we would talk together
and we would work with this person
together to develop
um some of the strategies that would
help and one thing I'll tell you John
just give an example one thing I learned
from a therapist this is a psychology
thing
people don't like to take things away or
feel restricted but they don't mind
adding things they don't mind adding
things so I'll give you an example
I could say to somebody
um I don't want you to take anything out
of your diet right now
I just want you to try to hit these
protein targets and I'd give them a goal
okay let's I want you to eat 120 grams
of protein a day don't cut anything else
out of your diet but when you eat your
your meals make sure you eat the protein
first and then you could eat everything
else now why does that work
because in the science well 100 support
this the data is very clear
protein produces tremendous satiety yeah
so when they hit those protein targets
they would almost always eat less
calories but I didn't tell them to eat
less calories I just told them need
protein
so uh you know this is just one this is
one thing I learned from working with a
therapist
or working with therapists on how to
make this a much more effective strategy
because the look we can't we can't
separate the physio the physiological
from the psychological they're both
they're both closely connected amen dude
yeah yeah and what we try to focus on
what we focus on too much
with diet and exercise and all that
stuff is the physiological what's the
best diet what produces the best fat
loss muscle gain insulin response this
that and the other meanwhile every diet
John every diet has a fail rate that's
north of 85 I don't care what it is so
it's not we're not messing up with the
physiological aspect it's the other part
that that every time I I talk to you I
walk away with something new that I just
put in my back pocket that's huge right
there
that that
at some point we have to realize it's
not the math problem it's busted it's
the way we're approaching the problem
um 100 100 and and food is a hard one uh
you you know you mentioned something
that was hard about it in that um it's
it's uh we have to eat it it's widely
accepted to eat in in lots of different
ways and we don't learn to eat uh we
don't learn the skills
that help us lead a healthy
life in modern society we just don't we
what ended up happening is in a very
short period of time within Generations
John we went from food is scarce and
hard to come by to there's so much food
and so much variety and so many choices
that it's crazy so we have the the we
learned the skills to to to survive it's
like my parents and my grandparents
right where they you better finish all
your meal you know your food or whatever
like that that right there was mostly
human history now it's like food is
everywhere we just don't we haven't
learned these so we grew up without any
of these skills like how do we navigate
a life
or in a world where there's so much
delicious tasty convenient incredible
cheap
food if we don't have the skills to to
navigate it so it's it's no wonder well
I love what you that word is is Magic
and it's it's been magic with married
couples and with parents
um who you know can't stop yelling at
their kid or they think they can't stop
yelling at their kids or they snap at
their loved ones
when you reframe it from hey you're not
a terrible human being with no character
you don't have you need some new skills
There's Something Magic about that that
it unhooks all of this extra
psychological baggage that we have and
it's like oh cool okay I can learn to
shoot a free throw if given enough time
um I can learn then these new set of
skills I love that reframe hey I'm Gonna
Let You Go dude you are a saint like
always thank you for
um this is a last second Hail Mary and
you caught the ball so I'm grateful for
you and like always I'm really grateful
for your wisdom and just the Practical
care with which you take care of human
beings who come to you and say hey
please help especially on a touchy
subject like this thank you so much man
I appreciate I appreciate it John you're
a special person I appreciate uh you
having me on so thank you all right take
care good man appreciate it easy all
right good folks we'll be right back on
the Dr John delone show
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back and let's go out
to Jay in Rochester Hills in Michigan
what's up Jay
Dr John deloney what's going on man dude
we are we are rocking onto the brick of
dawn my man how are you
I am doing great man thank you so much
for taking the time to take my call you
got it you got me yeah man before we get
started I want to say that I 100 agree
with you this is the best mental health
podcast on the planet that's what I'm
talking about Jay thank you so so much
um I mean that's like your good deed for
the year you're good man you can just
kind of be a reckless jerk from here on
out you've done your good deed thank you
so much man no problem brother no
problem all right so hey um in a it it
almost never happens I I got the
entirety of your email this time
um Jenna sent it to me and
um I actually reached out to the one of
the one of the two or three experts that
I trust more than anybody in the country
on this particular topic and this
particular issue to get some make sure I
was dialed in and I was going to be able
to help you
um and so man uh I I can't wait to jump
into this stuff
yeah I'm very excited um it's something
I've been struggling with for a while so
I feel like you are the best to give me
some insight on this topic well I don't
know if I'm the best but I will uh I'll
do my absolute best to tell you what I
do and don't know and um I it's an honor
to just to pull up a seat at the table
and and hear your story so tell me
what's going on
Yeah man so
I feel like I am a very disciplined
person
um
but I have a real bad struggle and
addiction to sugar and I feel like it is
my coping mechanism after a bad day
I feel like I could do I can go two to
three weeks without having it and all of
a sudden if I have a bad day at work
or or a few bad days of work I end up
having
three large Milkshakes that week and
it's like a never-ending cycle and I
really just struggle with it and I want
to kick that habit and
I already work out you know I work out
five to seven days a week and
um I actually use you're a big fan of
this guy I'm a huge fan of this guy of
Dr Lane Norton I use carbon I track
everything but it's like
something comes over me where the sugar
dopamine kicks in and I just have to
have it and I'll do whatever it takes to
get sugar
so you are a uh yeah Lane is incredible
um a brilliant Guy and um
I can't I I kind of want to look around
to make sure this isn't I'm not in a
weird dream and I'm calling myself on my
own show all right
um right so
why do you work out
I work out well I'm
29 now so I'll be 30 next year so lately
I've been working out to keep myself
healthy but before then I've always just
loved working out I love the the stress
reliever that it brings
when did you start working out
oh I would say I've been working out
since I was a young kid young teenager
so right when I play sports you know
you you wrote something here on your
email
that
I I I say raise the flag for me okay
I'll use that
you wrote here
I'm afraid if I don't get my poor
choices with food under control
I'm gonna die early or end up on my 600
pound life that show
yeah that's a
that tell me I'm wrong that sounds like
somebody
who is looking in the mirror and is not
happy with who they see
I would say that's a fair statement
so let's move the food stuff down I I'm
on a scale of one to ten what is the
shame intensity after that third
milkshake
oh man I would say
uh 10 for sure like go
in a hole and
don't come out
and words like you are sick you're
disgusting
that's ridiculous am I onto it yeah
you're on to it like what's wrong with
you bro why would you do this that's
horrible you know better than that whose
voice is that Jay that's not yours whose
voice is that
uh
the the standards I put on myself maybe
nah dude somebody told you that your
value was
not innate
yeah
who said you better you better dance you
better perform for me or your value and
lovability goes down who said that
I can honestly say that
it probably was someone in my within my
small circle of family growing up okay
or maybe or or maybe I dealt with a
great deal of trauma being raised by a
single mother that
I think and thought that I had to become
a people pleaser
to make everyone and everything around
me happy and so when things didn't go
that way
I feel like I would put myself in a bad
position and stress myself out and if
that makes sense well yeah because
one person gets hurt
in the presence of a rock star people
pleaser
and that's the people pleaser because
you gotta you gotta sacrifice yourself
to make sure everybody else is okay
and if you grew up in a house uh a
traumatic house you grew up in a house
that was that was a mess it was chaotic
um single malt was just tough
um
it's very common that people exit that
situation by controlling every possible
variable
I will control every every perception
somebody has of me every word that comes
out of my mouth my posture how clean my
clothes are my the Precision of my
workouts the the the amount of to the to
the to the t uh the the calories that go
in my body is that you
that's me okay
and
at some point that grip you have
your body gets exhausted
because you can't hold it all
right
and then We're Off to the Races right
we're off in the drive-throughs
exactly yeah man you're you're talking
to me
agents of the choir for sure
so
um
guys have become good good buddies of
mine
um there's basically two people I trust
when it comes to Fitness Nutrition
it's Lane Dr Norton
and Sal and Adam and Justin with the
Mind pump guys
and so when you hear this episode
entirely what you'll hear is beforehand
before this call I was on the phone with
Sal and I actually read him your email
I said hey man
um Sal's an expert he's been a personal
trainer for years and then he started
training trainers and he got so fed up
with the nonsense and the Fitness and
Nutrition industry they started their
own show and they're incredible they
just are doing great work
and one thing that um I'll never forget
he told me in person when we were
hanging out in San Jose and that he just
reiterated um on the call before this
one is most people go to the gym because
they hate themselves
they think they're disgusting and
they're trying to going to the gym is a
punishment for being disgusting
for being lazy
and what he said was outside of a few
people on Instagram
that has a fail rate of 80 to 90 percent
over the Long Haul
same with restrictive dieting pick a
diet I'm going full this full that keto
this full protein this what
fail rate fail rate fail rate because
the root is I hate you and you're gross
and I am going to beat you into
submission
and all of us when we're beaten long
enough we revolt
right right or when life gets really
stressful
our
hitting ourselves and hating ourselves
doesn't doesn't
um
keep the stress away
and so it's not a prophylactic for
stress it's still going to show up and
so we don't have another alternative so
what do we do we go grab gummy bears and
more ice cream
and then that shame spiral starts dude
and we recommit to our apps the next day
and we start the whole Loop over again
yes it it's kind of like a never ending
cycle right yes
so
I'm just meeting you I can tell in five
minutes talking to you like you and I
would hang out I like you
yeah
and
you have one path forward
where did your dad go
he wasn't there he went to Tennessee
with another woman
when did he go
I was six
years old
I'm guessing there's a six-year-old that
sits inside your chest
wondering what the hell was so bad about
Jay that Dad wouldn't stick around
and I imagine there's a 14 year old boy
that sits inside of Jay's chest that
says I'll show him
I'll show you all
right
there's a 22 and a 25 year old Jay
who's getting really exhausted
how old are you now
I am
29.
are you running out of gas
running out of gas man that's why I'm on
the phone with you I got on the hotline
and called Dr John
tank almost on East
Jay's worth being loved man
yeah
and that jar that you've got sealed shut
inside that chest you gotta open it
and if you're like me you got to do it
with a therapist counselors hard stuff
there
because it feels like if I open this
thing you don't want to know the dragons
that come out
and what I'll tell you is something you
already know is that the dragons are out
you think you got them under control but
you don't
the only path forward for for any of us
man
including me including you
is just what my friend Sal says I have
to go to the gym
with a smile on my face because I'm
choosing to care for a guy that's worth
being loved
I like that I'm going to
be a guy who's a good Steward of his
body and I'm not going to eat that not
because it's not freaking delicious
I'm gonna do it because I love this guy
enough
that I want him to feel good in an hour
or two when his blood sugar crashes
through the floor
so I'm good guys thank you all so much
and do you see the difference between
that approach how light that is and how
like what what a gentle touch that is
moving through the world and how
different it is than
I don't eat carbs I don't eat carbs I
don't eat carbs and then you were just
huddled under a blanket eating a bag of
chips watching a movie on a Saturday
night all by yourself I mean you see the
difference
yeah absolutely
but I really do so to piggyback off of
that and I ask you uh question if you
don't mind bring it
so I love that thought and ideology
how do I make it practical on a
day-to-day basis
three three things okay
foreign
you have to chew man God I hate this I
would do anything I gotta I will give
two books uh signed books of in to any
of your choice to anybody who calls it
if they will come up with a better word
for what I'm about to say
the word here Jay is mindfulness
and I hate the word it sounds like some
dude with a beard on a cloud you know
like in a kind of a dressy thing
here's what it is when you start to
reach for whatever it is you're going to
reach for
being able to extend that gap between
what I feel like I need to do and the
thing I'm about to do I need some gummy
bears right now I need to go grab get a
milkshake I am getting that pizza out
can you pause long enough to ask
yourself
what am I covering up here
what is this gonna do for me
and what we're doing here in a lot it's
it's it's it's the word I use when I'm
talking to to couples and to parents and
to folks working on like you know
working through ADHD or their OCD or
whatever and it's the same word Sal used
when he's talking to people about their
eating and and exercise habits it's
simply learning a new set of skills
you're not a piece of trash Jay
you're not some kind of undisciplined
loser
you showed up to a basketball game and
you never dribbled a basketball before
these are new skills
I gotta learn new skills
I have one skill for dealing with stress
and it's
junk food
cool I'm gonna learn some new skills
that means when I get stressed and I'm
about to grab it I gotta catch myself
and then go huh
what's another thing I could do that
could it would make me feel good in this
moment
and we're gonna practice it for some
people it might be doing 50 jumping
jacks sprinting down the street grabbing
a Diet Coke it could be any number of
things it's going to be different for
everybody but we're gonna practice it
it's a new set of skills
I like that there's a um Dr Judd Brewer
I think he's at a gale has a uh an app
that's for anxiety and for stopping
smoking and he is crushing all the uh
traditional methods to stop smoking with
an app and all it is is he just wants
you to be very mindful when you're
smoking
how do you feel right before you smoking
right afterwards right and it's
disgusting it's your hands stink your
clothes stink right feels good for a
second the buzz is fine and then it's he
said people just quit because they're
thoughtful about it
and so it's thinking about how am I
going to feel in an hour after I just
nailed this mint chocolate chip ice
cream
I'm gonna feel ashamed I'm gonna feel
gross I'm gonna feel lethargic I'm not
gonna right all those things I'm just
gonna be mindful of it
um the second thing is is at some point
you're gonna have to get a counselor and
sit down and talk about your childhood
sit down talk about your adulthood and
make some plans for who I'm gonna be in
the back half of my life
all right
have you ever done that
I have not but I am totally open to it
my whole thing is as long as the outcome
is growth and peace I'm all for it
you're gonna you're gonna have to learn
what peace feels like because right now
peace feels like stress for you
peace is a fairy tale for Jay
when you're peaceful I I'll be willing
to bet money that you create chaos in
your life
yeah is that true
yeah
chaos feels
um normal it feels home
so for some people the the challenge is
you've got to go move your body you got
to go exercise you gotta go walk you
gotta go be with friends for you it's
gonna be the opposite you're gonna have
to learn peace
you're gonna have to learn Sabbath
you're gonna rest
my friend Ian simkin says if busyness is
your drug
stress will feel like a rest will feel
like stress
that's you
that's you taking every variable every
variable and just letting your hands off
the wheel and you're going to find out
that the car doesn't crash it's amazing
and here's the third thing you got to do
you gotta find one or two other grown
men in your area and tell them what
you're going through
all of it
okay and that's probably the scariest
thing of all
I can do it can you promise
promise man all right here's my here's
my uh
here is my uh uh wager with you okay
yeah let's do it I want you to go to the
Mind pump website all their workouts
their maps program Maps
they're the ones I work out with at my
house okay
okay I think they're some of the best in
the country
you pick anyone you want and you email
uh Jenna back and uh I'll give it to you
for free
you like how I did that they're actually
giving it to me and then I'll give it to
you for free but I like taking credit
for it
wow
number two
I'm gonna give you anything you want out
of out of my store okay
questions for humans books whatever that
is
if you call me back in three months and
let me know how your how your counseling
sessions going
how your new approach to my friend Jay
is going
the mindfulness
and
how your search for
some grown men Francis go
all right the fair
before you go to bed tonight I want you
to write six-year-old Jay a letter
okay and I want you to let six-year-old
Jay know
hey I see you buddy come here
dad left because something was wrong
with him not you
dad missed out on the greatest gift
that any man can get
that's holding their
baby
and be able to walk alongside that mess
of a little girl or little boy for the
duration of their life
okay
and tomorrow I want you to write 14 year
old Jay a note
says Dear 14 year old Jay
I'm 29 now you can stop fighting
stop running stop fighting I got this
bro you're a freshman in high school go
play
and I want you to physically feel inside
your chest
14 year old Jay leave your body
he's off the play
you've been fighting your fights for a
long time
this is Jay choosing freedom
foreign
with your therapist you're going to
write a letter the 29 year old Jay
the one that looks at you in the mirror
every morning you're gonna let that Jay
know hey man you've had a rough go of it
and you're still here
you're a stronger the most and braver
than most and more disciplined than most
you've been through hell and back and
through hell and back again
and you still stand
[Music]
and now we're gonna
be a good Steward of our body because we
get to
because we care for ourselves so much we
love ourselves so much not because we
have to not because we're fat because we
hate ourselves because we get to
[Music]
now we're talking about long-term life
change of course we're gonna use a
carbon app of course we're going to use
a workout programs of course we're gonna
do those things
but we're going to do them out of care
and love not out of hate
when you're worth being loved Jay
you're good man the world is better
because you are in it
all this turns around
when you believe that too my brother
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um
thank you all for joining us today
um do check out the Mind pump guys go to
mindpump.com
m-i-n-d-p-u-m-p-s guys are amazing and
listen got no Financial stake in
anything they do
um they just are the best of the best
and they're great human beings behind
closed doors they're guys with Integrity
good folks and I love shouting out folks
some that I don't have any stake in in
theirs in their financial success I'm
not making any not a penny off um their
programs they're the best of the best of
the best and I love putting that stuff
out there also check out lane Norton's
carbon app check out all the protein
shakes he uses again I don't make a dime
off of them outwork nutrition it's just
the best stuff there is it's so so good
uh make sure you check it check it out
um today's song of the day it's from The
Archies
I don't know the Archies
no you may not know them but come on you
know the song Right read the lyrics
you'll know it
songs I'm getting harassed
multi-generationally so here's the song
I think I should know
it's by The Archies it's called Sugar
Sugar
[Music]
uh honey honey
you are my candy girl and you've got me
wanting you honey ah sugar sugar you're
my candy girl and you've got me wanting
you
I've never heard this song in my life
I just can't believe the loveliness of
loving you I just can't believe it's
true ah sugar oh honey honey you're my
candy girl they're not big on changing
the lyrics they just like saying the
same things over and over again kind of
like a modern worship song when I kissed
you girl I knew how sweet a kiss could
be like the Summer Sunshine pour your
sweetness over me
oh honey honey you're my candy girl
[Music]
it's the strange world we live in I love
you guys stay in school don't do drugs